last night I had a very uncomfortable
situation we're at the club yeah what
happened I I did that he's laughing
right now I already I it's gotta be I
did stand-up what I did stand whatever
Ida stand-up about yeah
Jeremiah I'm leaving I'm about to walk
out scot-free we had a great time go to
another spot everything's gonna be great
Laugh Factory and Emily at the store
goes hey do you want to a spot in the
main room Joey's on it burrs on it Greg
Fitzsimmons on it I was like hell yeah
of course and we're walking through the
main room and she goes yeah you know
it's um it's like it's a benefit for
people on the spectrum and I'm like hold
on retired people here like once ago cuz
I just don't I was like I'll just pass I
don't know exactly how to do it you know
and then she was no no no it's like
people in a halfway house to me halfway
house is you were you know had some
drugs you maybe we're in jail locked up
and they're trying to bring the backyard
every person I usually say drop my I go
to drug addict we're drug every doesn't
matter NOLA so I go halfway that's okay
I'm walking in the back to some guys
with like beards like face tattoos oh my
god least some rough guys are trying to
get the light back together and I'm
excited because I'm like these guys
aren't gonna be finished [ __ ] I can
[ __ ] go in [ __ ] yeah
I get brought up onstage I do a couple
jokes things are going really well and
then I go into this bit
there's [ __ ] Ben right and you see how
like wine is now multiplied Wyatt it is
now by like a thousand that's what that
fuller room felt like really it got real
quiet I'm like this is weird
but you were crushing before that cuz I
saw you early on it was good I'm not I'm
not the guy who like says or killed
every said like I'm the most critical
self it was going it was no well yeah it
was going hard took a little turn and
then I would say I got it back up to
about like 50 percent right that's a
hard hold to dig out of it we were
artists we were deep deep south shows I
walk off stage and Diaz goes uh he goes
yes yes hey uh what why'd you closer to
[ __ ] joke it's a benefit for retouch
is for [ __ ] [ __ ] it's okay kid
don't worry buddy
oh the sound guy goes dude balls man to
do that [ __ ] joke and brothers rights
I went pretty well not 50% bro I go back
to the part rank don't know it because
we're just staring at you some people
were there just to see burr you don't
know what the [ __ ] is they just see bill
boots so I think all those people like
oh this is awesome and then all these
people that are taking care of a [ __ ]
at home are like what the [ __ ] is going
on I'm supporting dude dude the first
comic that went on I think was like
mentally challenged but I didn't know I
thought he was just a comic because you
know comics are a registry you know
comic can be awkward a little bit yes
yes yes I just thought he was awkward
and um I think I came talk about our
interaction but uh I felt so [ __ ] bad
yeah I felt so far you were to laugh
actor after that I went to laugh a
career that honestly the audience was
more [ __ ] chosen one not you two of
them was it was expected that one you
knew it was coming I walked in Jose okay
close eyes here I saw the arm canes out
front I know what I'm getting it's so
specific I don't know ever [ __ ] was
just everything who was the thing was
all the things yeah we spray our glory
now it's just taking on a different kind
of power right I got oh my god dude your
shoes are [ __ ] yeah it was just like
and if they were they were it's like you
never know when you went home you're
like in front of everyone you were like
shut the [ __ ] up no they're not yeah and
you get home you're like dude honestly
getting picked on for your clothes when
you were young riddled you worse than
anything else in the world it's no
matter what they can make fun of you
about if you got cheated on in front of
your friends by something you warmed up
in where it really did you keep it on
the food day yeah you got some first
period before school you're like what
the floor just picking it out in turn it
inside out
dude those job when I was a kid those
jackets starter jacket yeah I wore that
and I didn't my brother's tell me he'll
that older brother he's tell me oh cool
they were is it now scalably star jacket
school everyone's around me like dang
because there's like a low-income like
school so yeah white boy is a star
Jackie damn like dang that's a starter
jacket it is my first one it is my dude
I got roasted for the entire day like
you ever worry again no no aunt no yeah
we just say it was like yeah cuz I
didn't know what starter was wait you
not wear starter you can but I just
didn't I when the [ __ ] thought they
were saying starter your first Jam is
your first and I'm like yes my first one
some guy do it like a ESL school just
some remember that Roger performing for
memory
right there that was shop rockin that
the power Gerardo jacket baby I did have
that Charlotte Hornets one bro I knew it
dude and this was really smart a junior
high is actually what you have to do it
he in his backpack would bring a change
of clothes just in case he got [ __ ]
on on stuff that he wore I'm not kidding
he bringin different shirts are
different like different shirts or
different like smart yeah cuz he was
always so worried yeah I don't know what
he's doing but he was so worried about
people [ __ ] on him he would bring a
change of clothes and his mom I don't he
had friends like this his mom didn't let
him wear certain she was like you're not
wearing that out of you know like no she
just didn't she just restricted him from
getting certain kinds of clothes so he
would go out by him you know secretly
stuff him in his backpack and then
change a clothes change at school so his
mom never knew you didn't want she
didn't let him wear certain stuff like
if it was like a Tupac shirt she said
where did you get that from she would
like lose it if she saw him some [ __ ]
like that it was it was like black guys
or was it no just Sheila she's like rap
you know rap culture was like that era
when we were kids it was like our
parents were so against there's so many
parents against that like that could
that rise cuz it was it was so dominant
you don't I mean like yeah what hip-hop
did and it changed culture forever yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]